more than 7 million voters in Tunisia
are choosing their next president the
election is a test of the only democracy
to emerge from the 2011 Arab Spring
Hashima libera reports millions of
voters in Tunisia are deciding who
becomes the second democratically
elected president since the 2011
revolution enjoying a surge in support
mainly among the young law professor
hired an independent has promised to
overhaul state institutions fight
corruption and invest in marginalized
regions his rival media tycoon Nabil par
we is popular in poor areas where his
charity has been active over the last
few years
car.we has pledged to end poverty and
create job opportunities for millions of
people
the president must find solutions to the
economy improved security and rein in
the soaring price of food it's
unbelievable you buy a commodity for a
price and tomorrow it's incredibly more
expensive Taha health care must be
addressed health care and women should
be given more opportunities the first
round of the election was tight
Syed came in first followed by a car we
the latter was released from jail a few
days ago after being detained on charges
of corruption and tax evasion the leader
of the secular party heart of Tunisia
dismissed the accusations as politically
motivated the winner will be the one who
manages to convince Tunisians he has
answers to their growing economic
problems SOB [ __ ] then I don't see a
consensus on the governing coalition and
that means the political parties may not
agree on a plan of action me shaking
Luna attack we have a poor
infrastructure education was one of the
best end of region now it has declined
politically it's been a busy week in
Tunisia last Sunday a parliament was
elected and talks are underway to form a
coalition government the Conservative
Party in nava came in first followed by
Nabil par with heart of Tunisia
both have ruled out forming a coalition
leaving another with a delicate task of
convincing rivals and independent
members of parliament to join the
government whoever gets elected will
have to ensure the governing coalition
is formed quickly and measures are taken
to tackle poverty and economic problems
if people don't feel progress soon
that's my deepen the growing
disillusionment they feel towards their
leaders Hacha barbara al jazeera tunis